[Musique]
un immense territoire rempli de l'accès
de rivière c'est un projet titanesque
qui a fait entrer le Québec dans la
modernité il y a 50 ans à s'amorçait la
construction du complexe hydroélectrique
de la budgens un défi technologique et
logistique sans précédent qui fera
l'objet d'un documentaire représenter ce
dimanche à l'émission Découverte et son
animateur Charles est avec nous pour en
parler donc Charles vous êtes rendu
là-bas pour la toute première fois de
votre vie et ça a été un voyage marquant
en Russie la première fois que j'ai eu
la chance d'aller à la béjane écouter
après des décennies de journalistes on
aurait pu penser que ce serait là aller
avant mais c'est ça il faut s'y rendre
il faut s'y rendre une bonne raison ce
documentaire et on a eu la chance d'être
en hélicoptère dès le début alors on a
vu cet immense réservoir Robert Bourassa
qui se trouve au niveau de la rivière de
la grande et écoutez ces trois fois gras
comme le lac Saint-Jean c'est immense et
sais pas ce que c'était une forêt
auparavant la taille égale la forêt
boréale il y avait il y avait des lacs
il y avait quelques rivières mais
c'était surtout parcouru depuis des
milliers d'années par les Autochtones
qui vivent à l'écrire entre autres et
puis on regarde ça puis on se dit waouh
c'est quelque chose d'incroyable qu'on a
qu'on a fait là-bas et il a fallu s'y
rendre il a fallu construire une route
de plus de 600 km de Matagami à ce qui
aujourd'hui Radisson pour pouvoir monter
les équipements là-haut ça a été fait au
début sur des routes de neige et de
glace avec des panses glaces au dessus
des rivières il y avait des jeunes
cartographes dans la vingtaine c'est
beau de voir ces images là qui sautaient
des hélicoptères dans la neige des
hélicoptères pilotés par des pilotes
d'anciens pilote de la guerre du Vietnam
il y a eu un Hercule qui a été acheté
par Hydro-Québec pour monter des
équipements importants et puis on a
décidé de le faire à cet endroit là le
grand réservoir et la centrale et la
centrale elle est c'est la plus grande
centrale souterraine mais on dit
souterraine en fait elle a été foré dans
le rock dans le granite on a installé
des turbines alternateur 16 turbines
alternateur et moi ce qui m'a vraiment
frappé c'est le concept qui est si
simple c'est le gravité le poids de
l'eau qui descend dans les canalisations
qui actionnent les turbines à toute
vitesse et qui produit de l'électricité
verte c'est renversant et quand on pense
que c'est turbine là qui sont des
machines immenses pesant 200 tonnes qui
tournent comme ça toute vitesse quand on
pense qu'elles ont à peu près jamais été
entretenu ça pas été nécessaire parce
que dans le fond ce sont des pièces très
simples qui tournent toutes seules avec
la puissance de l'eau ça c'est vraiment
renversant et puis la géologie du coin a
beaucoup aidé de toute cette région
parce que les matériaux qui ont formé de
grands barrages qui est grand en fait
comme la pyramide de Khéops il est en
forme pyramidale d'ailleurs c'est c'est
matériaux là ont été utilisés pour
construire ce
et il a fallu l'asseoir sur quelque
chose de solide parce qu'il pèse cet
astronomique ce que pèse ce barrage là
et donc on a profité du fait que si le
Bouclier canadien qui est là haut et
puis l'un des ingénieurs qui a surveillé
et entretenu ce barrage pendant des
décennies Pedro et Hernandez nous parle
justement de ça donc on était capable
d'asseoir le barrage sur le roc de
fondation qui est un roc de très bonne
qualité on est dans le Bouclier canadien
on est dans les granites on est dans des
roches là qui sont parfaites là pour des
bonnes stabilité de l'ouvrage
et maintenant à côté du grand barrage il
y a un ouvrage impressionnant qui
s'appelle l'escalier du géant et que
l'on voit justement sur cette image
c'est très impressionnant et ça a une
fonction très importante aussi oui parce
que ce barrage là il est pas en béton il
est en terre et roche et on veut pas que
l'eau passe par dessus c'est des plus
diluviennes alors cet ouvrage là
l'escalier du géant a été conçu
justement pour protéger le barrage en
écoutant justement un sujet là Jean-Paul
fontaine qui est un des artisans de la
première heure oui lors d'une crue
vraiment exceptionnelle le niveau d'eau
pourrait dépenser les seuil dangereux et
à ce moment-là on ne soupape de sécurité
exactement comme le déversoir de trop
plein de votre baignoire oui ça
s'appelle une évacuateur c'est un
ouvrage qui peut déverser l'eau dans ce
qu'on appelle l'escalier du géant
faudrait faire un petit tour
sans heure vous parliez des cris un
petit peu plus tôt donc il y a eu des
tensions avec les cris les innoïdes qui
n'avaient pas été consultés même pas
prévenu de la construction de ce barrage
Robert Bourassa a lancé le projet du
siècle en 1971 ces consultations
n'avaient pas eu lieu alors quand les
autochtones ont compris qu'on allait
inondé une grande partie de leur
territoire ancestral ils se sont opposés
à ce projet-là il y a eu des
cojudiciaires très importants ça a été
médiatisé à travers le monde finalement
il y a eu l'entente de la convention de
la budget et du Nord québécois qui a
initié qui a permis aux travaux de
commencer puis ensuite il y a eu l'appel
des braves avec Bernard Landry alors
qu'il y a enchassé vraiment ce
partenariat avec les autochtones ce qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui on peut rien faire
de vraiment significatif dans toute
cette région là par Hydro-Québec sans
l'accord des autochtones on a bien hâte
de voir ça donc dimanche soir 18h30
merci beaucoup Charles d'avoir été avec
nous merci d'avoir invité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]